I love airplanes whoo
I love airplanes so when I went to
college in the late 90s it was obvious
that I was gonna study aerospace and you
wouldn't believe how many people told me
oh no not aerospace aerospace is gonna
be boring everything in aerospace has
already been done well there are a
little bit off the mark and in fact I
think the next decade is going to be
another golden age for aviation for one
thing and this is where I get excited
flight is about to get a lot more
personal so a little compare and
contrast in the last century large
commercial airplanes have connected
cities across the globe and a hundred
years ago it would have been unthinkable
for all of us to fly here from around
the world for a five-day conference but
we did and most of us probably without a
second thought
and that's a remarkable achievement for
Humanity but on a day to day basis we
still spend a lot of time in cars or
actively try to avoid it some of my best
friends live in San Francisco I live in
Mountain View about 40 miles away we're
all busy at the end of the day we're
separated by something like two hours a
heavy traffic so frankly we haven't seen
each other in a few months now I've
worked in downtown San Jose which is
near the airport and there are actually
days when I can leave work get on a
plane and fly to Los Angeles fast and I
can drive to San Francisco cities are
only getting more populated the roads
are full and it's really difficult to
expand them and so in a lot of places
there really aren't a lot of good
solutions for getting around traffic but
what if you could fly over it the sky's
under utilized and I would argue it will
never be as congested as the roads are
first of all you get a whole lot of
dimension but also just safety
considerations and air traffic
management will not allow
bumper-to-bumper traffic in the sky
which means in many cases flying can be
a long-term compelling alternative to
traveling on the ground so imagine this
you call an uber it takes you to a
nearby landing spot we call these
verdict ports there's an airplane
waiting for you there fly
overall the traffic in the middle and on
the other side another uber takes you to
a friend's house and I said uber but I
think we really need to congratulate the
lyft branding team for their
forward-thinking and choosing their
brand so so in that example okay there
are a few extra steps I admit but it's
30 minutes versus two hours it cost
around $60 and you get to fly
we're not there yet but we are a lot
closer than you might think
so one of the first things we need is we
need an aircraft that can take off and
land at small spaces and quickly take
you where we want to go and helicopters
can't do that today but traditionally
helicopters have been just a little bit
too expensive just a little too hard to
pilot and just a little too noisy to be
used for daily transportation in cities
well electric flight and autonomy are
changing that electric flight in
particular unlocks new possibilities for
vehicle configurations that we just
could not explore in the past if use
electric motors you can have many of
them around the aircraft and it doesn't
add a lot of extra weight and that gives
you redundancy and safety and also
they're cleaner cheaper and quieter than
internal combustion engines autonomy
allows the transportation network to
scale and and I actually think it makes
the aircraft safer commercial flights
are already automated for most of the
duration and I believe there will come a
day when we won't even trust an airplane
that required a human to fly it so one
of our teams that a cubed wanted to see
just how close this future really was so
they built and flew a prototype of one
such vehicle and they made a point of
only using mature commercially available
technologies today we call it vahana
it's fully electric I takes off and
lands vertically but flies forward like
a regular airplane it's fully self
piloted you push a button it takes off
flies and lands all by itself the
prototype that you see here is designed
to carry a single passenger and luggage
and it can go about 20 miles in 15
minutes and our estimate for a trip like
that is it would cost around $40 which
you can really build a business around
it has multiple redundant motors and
batteries you can lose one and will
continue flying online normally
it's pretty quiet when it's flying
overhead it will be quiet and I Prius on
the highway it's intelligent it has
cameras lidar and radar so it can detect
and avoid unexpected obstacles and the
team really focused on making it
efficient so the batteries are small
lights and they last longer
for reference the vahana battery is less
than half the size of a Tesla Model S
battery it's about 40 kilowatt hours and
you can hot-swap the batteries in just a
few minutes so yeah and I do think that
in a few years people will be
comfortable getting by themselves in a
self piloted electric VTOL air taxi but
the team is busy working on the next
version which is going to carry at least
two passengers and fly quite a bit
farther but more importantly there are
over 20 companies around the world
working on vehicles just like this one
right now my best guess is in the next
five years you'll start seeing vertic
ports in some cities and little airplane
icons on your right sharing apps and it
might begin my began well it doesn't but
eventually we could have hundreds of
these flying around our cities and it
will fundamentally transform our
relationship with local travel in the
past century flight connected our planet
in the next it will reconnect our local
communities and I hope it will reconnect
us to each other thank you
but okay so when these things first roll
out right now it's it's a it's a single
person aircraft right so these yes yours
yours this I mean someone comes out of
their car the door opens they get in
there's no one else in there
the sink takes off I mean can we do a
poll here because these are early
adopters in this room I want to know who
here is excited about the idea of being
picked up solo in an auto flying craft
well there you go that is pretty awesome
half of Ted is completely start staring
bonkers so one of the one of the things
we're really focusing on is really the
cost so you can really wrap a business
around that and so that that's why some
of the features are really driven by
price and the forty dollar price tag is
really a target that we're aiming for
which should make it accessible to a
larger crowd than this one the biggest
blockage in terms of when this rolls out
is probably not the technology at this
point is its regulation right that's
probably true yes I would I would agree
with that the technology needs to mature
in terms of safety to get to the safety
levels that we expect from from aircraft
but I don't think there are any blockers
there it's just work needs to get done
so first this is ride-sharing I mean we
that far away from a time when lots of
people have one of these in their garage
and just kind of go direct to their
friend's house my my personal view is
that the ride-sharing actually allows
you to operate that entire business much
more efficiently I you know there are
there are Millennials that say they
never want to own a car I think they'll
probably feel even stronger about
aircraft so I I really I really think
that the network scales and operates a
lot better as ride-sharing platform also
because the integration would air
traffic management works a lot better if
it's if it's handled centrally cool
thank you for that thank you that was
amazing